[inaudible]
they're at the door!
[jingling]
Royal guards!
Attack!
[shouting]
[screaming]
Behind you!
[shouting]
Come on!
Shut the door!
Brace the doors!
[inaudible].
What is it?
Gawain.
Knights of Saint Lazarus,
for your attempt to raise arms
against King Philip, you are
now declared enemies of France,
along with everyone you harbor,
including the Knights Templar.
[shouting]
Are those all your weapons?
We're not accustomed
to spilling blood
in a house of Christ.
Be grateful we have this many.
We should bring the
fight to them instead
of waiting for the inevitable.
I count 20 men
along this wall.
That's 50 total.
They'll slaughter us
one by one, with archers
trained on the door.
We'd be fools.
Unless they want us alive.
I'll give my life before
I'll be taken prisoner.
Never again.
I'm sorry, Landry,
for all of this.
I never should have
involved the Templars.
We've always
fought side by side.
Tonight we'll die side by side.
It won't come to that.
You've seen how
many men there are.
We've no way out.
God will provide
us with a way.
Take cover!
Let's go!
Stand!
Quickly!
[inaudible] windows.
Gabriel!
God has provided
us with an answer!
There's too many!
[shouting]
Charge!
[screaming]
Gawain!
[shouting]
What is the meaning of this?
What's happened?
Landry.